en quelques minutes il y avait 1,50
d'eau chez moi c'est vraiment une
catastrophe j'ai pris une échelle pour
monter sur mon toit car l'eau montait
vite très vite mes animaux vont mourir
j'ai peur de mourir ce sont les mots
d'habitants du montrelois du Boulonnais
du calisi et de l'odomarois qui ont vu
leur maison être prise par les EOS ces
déchaînements ont non seulement ravagé
des zones agricoles des entreprises mais
également détruit nos infrastruc
structure école routes et surtout
endommager de nombreuses habitations
derrière cette catastrophe c'est d'abord
des familles dévastées et probablement
beaucoup de rêves brisés qui nous
appartient de reconstruire aujourd'hui
les pompes manque pour palier la hausse
du niveau de la mer il a fallu déménager
jeudi soir deux pompes du lac d'Ardre
pour les mettre sur la commune de
balingon les bassins de rétention sont
sous-dimensionnés ou mal entretenus les
cantonniers communaux ont disparu faute
de moyens les fossées les rivières les
watergang des wateringues ne sont plus
curé car par endroit pour ne pas
importuner quelques grenouilles ou
anguill l'on préfère laisser des
personnes âgées les pieds dans l'eau le
P decaléis a effectivement connu un
événement pluvieux intense ces derniers
jours qui faisait suite à des cumuls
déjà exceptionnel intervenant dans un
contexte hydrologique extrêmement
préoccupant sur les 247 communes qui ont
été touché la priorité est à la réponse
d'urgence et au retour à la
normale 550 foyers restent privés
d'électricité celle-ci ne pourra être
rétablie par les services enéis que
lorsque le niveau de l'eau permettra de
mettre hors d'eau les postes électriques
92 axes routiers soit 150 km de route
reste encore coupé les établissements
scolaires demeurent fermés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui vous évoquez la question du
relogement des sinistrés la prise en
charge s'est concentrée sur les
personnes vulnérables depuis le 6
novembre 54 d'entre elles ont été prises
en charge par l'ARS dans un hébergement
dédié en ce qui concerne la
reconstruction suite aux dégâts causés
par les inondations les personnes
physiques résidant dans l'une des 244
communes ayant fait l'objet d'une
reconnaissance par l'état de catastrophe
naturelle pourront faire l'objet d'une
indamnisation des dommages causés au
bien assurés ce qui devrait permettre
une et favoriser la reconstruction une
cellule dédiée aux entreprises et aux
exploitants agricoles a également été
mise en place par la préfecture la
fréquence et l'intensité de ces
phénomènes climatiques ayant vocation à
s'accélérer dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique nous devons
adapter nos territoires pour y fa faire
face et c'est le sens du nouveau plan
national d'adaptation de la France au
changement climatique qui est porté par
Christophe Béchu et qui sera lancé en
début d'année 2024 je vous remercie